und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend in berlin ist ein parteitag von
bündnis 90 die grünen zu ende gegangen
wie es noch nie einen gab beim ersten
parteitag vor 41 jahren hat sich das
kaum jemand vorstellen können
start in einen wahlkampf in dem eine
kandidatin der grünen anspruch auf das
kanzleramt erhebt und in union und spd
die den ersten platz im bundestag immer
unter sich ausmachten konnten lacht
keiner dieser aussicht hatte deutlich
erkennbar einem mäßigende zur mitte hin
treibende wirkung auf debatten und
abstimmungen in berlin
patricia wiedemeier berichtet und dann
sprechen wir mit kanzlerkandidat in
werbung drei tage und ursprünglich mehr
als 3000 änderungsanträge liegen hinter
ihnen die grünen haben ein wahlprogramm
angenommen fast ohne gegenstimmen und
jetzt stehen wir da geschlossen geeint
entschlossen das war jetzt der einfache
teil und jetzt beginnt der richtige
wahlkampf nicht so einfach war heute die
abstimmung über bewaffnete drohnen die
mehrheit für ein grundsätzliches ja
äußerst knapp die einsatzszenarien
müssten jedoch klar definiert werden
außerdem wollen die grünen einen höheren
co2 preis mehr geld für hartz 4
empfänger 12 euro mindestlohn nicht alle
sind happy
im bereich der sozialen gerechtigkeit
sind wir mit unseren linken grüne jugend
forderungen noch mal rein gegangen
hier haben wir uns gewünscht noch mal
linkere positionen zu setzen das hat
leider nicht geklappt
mehr links zu radikal das war die sorge
der parteispitze am ende entscheiden
sich die delegierten bei nahezu allen
abstimmungen pragmatisch sprich fürs
regieren
wir werden im wahlkampf uns häufig
anhören müssen wir wollen zu viel wir
wollen zu schnell
aber alles was sie beschlossen haben
lässt sich bei optimalen bedingungen in
der wirklichkeit umsetzen prominente
wahlkampfhilfe die weißrussische
widerstandskämpferin tüchern auf scania
kommt zum parteitag ihre rede berührt
ihre botschaft europa ist nur sicher
wenn velaros sicher ist deutschland habe
dabei eine schlüsselrolle
danke dass ihr velaros eine stimme in
deutschland gibt danke für euer
aufrichtiges engagement in osteuropa und
die kenntnisse die die grüne partei
beisteuert es war sein parteitag robert
habeck überall er redet mit journalisten
betreut die gäste hält wichtige gegen
rehden bei den abstimmungen an der lena
baerbock dagegen tritt kaum in
erscheinung und wenn wirkte angespannt
und nervös verärgert über einen nicht
wirklich schweren versprecher in ihrer
rede
es folgt ein shitstorm in den sozialen
netzwerken heute der rückendeckung von
der partei die attacken der anderen
seien nur ausdruck ihrer angst vor
starken grünen so winfried kretschmann
kannst dich zu 100 prozent auf uns
verlassen
die ganze partei steht geschlossen
hinter dir
die partei ist geeint wie nie das
wahlprogramm nicht verschärft die beste
voraussetzungen also für eine
kanzlerkandidatin eigentlich in der tat
die spitzenkandidatin hat den parteitag
unterm strich gut überstanden
nach den schlechten zahlen in sachsen
anhalt und in umfragen nach den pannen
ungenauigkeiten und korrekturen der
letzten tage und dann noch der
unbeherrschtheit gestern guten abend
frau berbalk wenn sie auf sich selbst
zurück schauen über die letzten wochen
sehen sie da immer eine zukünftige
kanzlerin
schönen guten abend wir haben jetzt
einen fulminanten parteitag hinter uns
wo wir es wurde im beitrag ja auch
deutlich erstmalig seit 40 jahren eine
kanzlerkandidatin aufstellen und das ist
für unsere partei natürlich was neues
für mich was neues und da hat es am
anfang auch geruckelt aber genau darum
geht es jetzt in diesem wahlkampf geht
für mich in den nächsten vier jahren
dinge in zukunft besser zu machen als
gesellschaft als land und da wächst man
natürlich auch selber als person wenn
man noch mal zurück schaut auf diese
korrekturen im lebenslauf ohne da jetzt
ins kleinkarierte zu gehen
die hatten alle so einen gemeinsamen
trend die neigten alle dazu den
lebenslauf so ein bisschen gewichtiger
aussehen zu lassen
spricht das nicht dafür dass sie selbst
das gefühl haben die reine wahrheit
würde nicht ganz reichen wäre zu leicht
nein ganz und gar nicht sondern mit
blick auf die darstellung in meinem
lebenslauf ging es mir darum vor allen
dingen verbindungen deutlich zu machen
dass es für mich wirklich zentral in der
politik deutlich zu machen da ich viel
in der klimapolitik bin bei welchen
vereinen bei welchen mitgliedschaften
bei mir verbindungen verstehen bestehen
auch in der außenpolitik und das war an
manchen stellen etwas ungenau deswegen
ist ein eindruck entstanden den ich
nicht zu hervorrufen wollte und erst
das an dieser stelle dann entsprechend
korrigiert und die tatsache dass die
ungenauigkeiten immer in richtung mehr
gewicht gehen ist einfach ein zufall
wie gesagt mir ging es darum vorliegen
deutlich zu machen wo es
mitgliedschaften wo es verbindungen gibt
und verkürzung kompakt das ganze auf
einer webseite darzustellen
mich hat das selber sehr geärgert dass
da ein missverständlicher eindruck
entstanden ist
den habe ich entsprechend korrigiert und
jetzt ist für mich aber zentral
wir stehen nach la corona pandemie vor
wirklichen zukunftsaufgaben das haben
wir mit diesem parteitag deutlich
gemacht es geht um die erneuerung
unseres landes es geht darum die größte
krise unserer generation die klimakrise
abzuwenden und zugleich für den ganzen
alle punkte des wahlprogramms kommen und
ich verspreche ihnen wir werden über die
nächsten monate pausenlos über die
wahlprogramme der parteien berichten
noch mal zu dem parteitag zurück da sind
sie ja jetzt sehr gut durchgekommen
durch diesen dschungel von 3.000
änderungsanträgen und meistens ist das
was die spitzenkandidaten und
vorsitzenden wollte gut durchgekommen
aber ist nicht im kern die grüne partei
doch immer noch die partei die darüber
diskutieren muss ob das wort deutschland
vorne auf dem programm stehen darf die
tempolimit hunderte ernsthaft vorschlägt
was sicher keine mehrheit in deutschland
hat die dreimal viermal höhere co2
preise will möglichst noch heute abend
den ausstieg aus dem verbrennungsmotor
haben will und so weiter lauter dinge
die jetzt hintan gestellt wurden
aber die doch möglicherweise wieder
rauskommen wenn die macht erstmal
erreicht ist und da würde ich jetzt
gerne ein sehr deutlich
differenzierteres bild geben weil ich
glaube deswegen habe ich das eben auch
so angesprochen es geht um wirklich
große fragen unserer zeit
wie schaffen wir es wirtschaft und
klimaschutz versöhnen und gleichzeitig
für mehr soziale gerechtigkeit zu sorgen
und die flotte an dem punkt anpacken bei
der wichtigste ist auch für sie der
wichtigste
sie wollen jetzt das in neun jahren die
verbrennungsmotoren in deutschland nicht
mehr zugelassen werden
das bedeutet das was deutsche ingenieure
am besten können von allen in der welt
nämlich verbrennungsmotoren wird
abgeschafft elektromotoren kommen die
ganz bestimmt gute sache sind aber sehr
sehr viel weniger arbeitsplätze brauchen
weil die nämlich sehr viel
richter zu montieren sind keine getriebe
brauchen und so weiter 200.000
arbeitsplätze wird das kosten wie
erklären sie das den familien die in
acht jahren davon noch leben wollen dass
er wohlstand unseres landes im letzten
jahrhundert ohne frage zum einen auf dem
verbrennen von kohle öl und gas und auch
eben entsprechenden autos aufgebaut war
diese diesen wohlstand der da geschaffen
wurde das hat deutschland stark gemacht
aber wir leben jetzt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert da ist
klar die märkte der zukunft sind
klimaneutral
auch die automobilmärkte und deswegen
ist es ja kein zufall dass deutsche
hersteller zum beispiel nach china die
deutlich gemacht haben ihr braucht eine
gewisse quote von elektroautos ganz
viele elektroautos nach china
exportieren und ich möchte dass wir auch
in deutschland nicht nur diese autos
herstellen und dann in der welt sie
exportiert werden sondern sie auch auf
deutsche straßen kommen damit es bei uns
auch leiser weil elektroautos sind ja
auch leiser sauberer und weniger co2
emissionen gibt und alle deutschen
automobilkonzern haben sich genau auf
den weg gemacht diesen weg zu gehen und
jetzt braucht es einen klaren sicheren
rahmen von der politik damit wir die
frage arbeitsplätze die sie an
geschaffen haben dafür sorgen dass die
arbeitsplätze in deutschland erhalten
sein dass die autos weiter in
deutschland und der 200.000
arbeitsgeräte weniger und was erklären
sie diesen 200.000 familie sie wollen
den acht jahren noch ihren job so
ausüben wie heute genau und genau das
will ich auch und deswegen bin ich seit
langem gespräche mit dem konzern aber
genauso mit den gewerkschaft mit der ig
metall die genau deutlich gemacht habe
wo fallen jobs weg unser vorschlag ist
es dafür ein qualifizierungs
kurzarbeitergeld dass die menschen die
dort beschäftigt sind die in acht jahren
jetzt noch nicht in rente gehen sondern
weiter ihre familien von den einkommen
entsprechend abhängen dass sie
weiterqualifiziert werden das ist auch
keine erfindung der grün sondern das
haben wir bei vielen transformationen
schritten gerade industrie immer wieder
gemacht und genau deswegen braucht es
eine planungssicherheit wenn ich nicht
sagen wie das nächste jahrzehnt aussieht
dann können wir das nicht sozial sicher
in deutschland gemeinsam gestalten und
diese sicherheit möchte ich für die
transformation die ohne frage kommen
wird für deutschland geben
ich würde gleich noch einen
abschließenden augenblick auf die
außenpolitik gehen weil wir gleich über
den g 7 gipfel
cornwall berichten werden da hat sich
herausgestellt dass präsident beiden
wirklich harte kante gegen china vor
allem aber auch gegen russland fahren
will die kanzlerin rät da zur mäßigung
und bremst den amerikanischen
präsidenten eine kanzlerin berbalk würde
die er so denken wie joe biden oder ihr
wir angenommen hat mein klarer kurs in
der außenpolitik ist dialog und härte
gegenüber autoritären regime
das betrifft russland das betrifft china
wir haben natürlich selber interessen
wir haben gerade mit blick auf china
was wir gerade besprochen hatten eine
große frage auch von importen und
exporten aber wir können nicht negieren
dass wir eine wertegemeinschaft sind als
europäer und zwar nicht nur reagieren
sondern dass es unser fundament als
starke europäische union als starkes
deutschland und deswegen darf man zu
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china
zwangsarbeit nicht schweigen und zum
beispiel mein vorschlag ganz konkret zu
sagen wir sind der größte binnenmarkt
der welt als europäer
wir können klar sagen produkte aus
zwangsarbeit aus china kommen nicht auf
den europäischen markt das wird die
beiden sicher und angela merkel
möglicherweise freuen danke für das
gespräch und einen guten abend
danke ebenso schönen abend vom abschluss
des g 7 gipfel von dem wir gerade
redeten die erste station der ersten
europa reise von präsident joe biden
berichtet jetzt andreas kühner
es ist kühler geworden als vorher
gedacht zwischen den verhandlungen und
zwischen den verhandlern die warme decke
scheint nötig zu sein und der behagliche
grillabend auch als sich die mächtigen 7
gestern abend bei makrele und
rinderfilet wiederfinden liegt bereits
ein bisschen enttäuschung in der nach
holzkohle duftenden luft enttäuschung
für joe biden der in cornwall jeden tag
mit der botschaft zur arbeit geht die g7
sind wieder da weil die usa wieder da
sind
aber dann bekommt es das pathos des
amerikaners mit deutschen pragmatismus
zu tun
kanzlerin merkel sagt nein zu beiden
wunsch die impfstoff patente frei zu
geben sagt nein zu einer allzu brüsken
verurteilung chinas und sagt nein es
läuft ganz toll mit beiden schauen sie
durch die wahl von vier beiden zum
amerikanischen präsidenten ist ja die
welt nicht so dass sie keine probleme
mehr hätte aber wir können mit neuem
elan an der lösung dieser probleme
arbeiten wie der elan ist
unterschiedlich verteilt das zeigt sich
vor allem beim gipfel großthema china
für den kurs härte sind die usa
großbritannien frankreich und kanada
im team vorsicht sind deutschland und
die übrigen europäer als so sensibel
empfinden die gastgeber die china
diskussion dass sie im sitzungsraum das
internet abstellen es geht um sehr viel
beiden findet es geht um alles das mag
jetzt etwas prosaisch klingen aber ich
glaube wir sind im wettkampf nicht mit
china per se sondern im wettkampf mit
autokratischen regierungen um die frage
können sich die demokratin mit ihnen
messen im sich so schnell verändernden
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert in ihrer
abschlusserklärung üben die westlichen
staaten scharfe kritik an den
menschenrechtsverletzungen chinas und
kündigen milliardeninvestitionen als
gegengewicht zu pekings seitenstraße an
dies ist der meeres und der klima
notstand schreiben die demonstranten vor
die küste cornwalls sie sind so
friedlich wie selten diesmal und so
enttäuscht wie immer der protest zwingt
die g7 ihre absicht
klärungen zu verteidigen alle hier haben
einen erheblichen schritt gemacht in
richtung der 100 milliarden dollar
die wir bis zur klimakonferenz zusammen
haben wollen um den entwicklungsländern
bei klimaprojekten zu helfen als die
anderen sechs den gipfel verlassen haben
hat der g siebte noch einen termin
das vereinigte königreich hat in den
letzten drei tagen alles gegeben um die
brics it gegner und zweifler zu
versöhnen der gastgeber hat es in vollen
zügen genossen und ist gleich nach dem
gipfel abgetaucht wir haben geprüft
blieb über wasser unsere amerika
korrespondent el mati wissen ist mit dem
präsidenten unterwegs der morgen in der
schweiz oder dicksten tage in der
schweiz auf putin und erdogan treffen
wird mit wie viel rückenwind von diesem
gipfel vor allen dingen trifft er sich
mit ladino putin immer also ich glaube
er hat sich mehr rückenwind erhofft joe
biden wollte ja in diesen tagen
gewissermaßen sein wichtigstes werkzeug
schmieden im umgang mit putin aber auch
mit erdogan
und das ist eben einigkeit und das hätte
bedeutet dass putin und andere nicht
gelingen könnte amerika zu ignorieren
weil man vielleicht dann andere
geschäfte machen kann mit europäern und
anderen staaten aus dem kreis der g 7
also die macht oder der hebel den joe
biden in der hand hätte für dieses
gespräch am mittwoch in genf hängt
wirklich davon ab inwieweit die europäer
ihm den rücken stärken
nun kennt der putin schon länger er hat
einmal eine begegnung geschrieben in
einem interview aus dem märz 2011 mit
wladimir putin da soll die beiden nach
eigenen angaben zu ihm gesagt haben ich
schaue ihnen in die augen herr putin
ich kann keine seele darin erkennen und
putin soll so beschreibt beiden es
geantwortet haben wir verstehen einander
also man sieht im grunde es gibt kein
vertrauen gegenüber dem russischen
präsidenten und so koch das weiße haus
jetzt die erwartungen ein stück weit für
mittwoch herunter
man sagt in erster linie kommt es darauf
an einmal klar zu machen was man
voneinander hält dann noch sehr klar zu
machen was man voneinander
erwartet also auch forderungen zu
stellen in beide richtungen
und wenn man dann das gefühl bekommt
dass man weiß was man voneinander zu
erwarten hat dann ist man da eigentlich
mit diesem gipfeltreffen schon zufrieden
es kommt noch etwas dazu wenn es
konflikte gibt und eskalationen dann
will man jetzt wieder
kommunikationskanäle haben nach diesem
gipfel treffen um diese dann zu rate zu
ziehen um vielleicht lösungen zu finden
aber der amerikanische präsident will
das hat er angekündigt auf keinen fall
eine gemeinsame pressekonferenz mit
wladimir putin weil er will nicht dass
das treffen nachher danach beurteilt
wird wer die längste redezeit hatte ob
es einen handschlag gegeben hat und ob
ich sag mal putin ihn möglicherweise
sehr salopp abgekocht hat also wird ein
spannendes treffen aber große
entscheidungen großer vereinbarungen
sind am mittwoch sicherlich nicht zu
erwarten
aber der eindruck von zwei männern die
irgendwie miteinander zurechtkommen
müssen dankeschön elmer und wir kommen
weiter zu den nachrichten in israel ist
heute abend eine ära zu ende gegangen
benjamin netanyahu ist nach zwölf jahren
nicht mehr regierungschef
ihm folgt eine koalition der
widersprüche nachrichten von hundt oder
gar die neue regierung in israel wurde
gerade eben vereidigt acht parteien
haben sich in einer breiten koalition
zusammengefunden die fast das gesamte
politische spektrum israels abbildet sie
eint vor allem der wunsch eine regierung
ohne den langjährigen
ministerpräsidenten netanjahu zu bilden
dessen nachfolger ist der
ultranationalist bennett nach zwei
jahren soll er von dem liberalen rapid
als ministerpräsident abgelöst werden
ob das fragile bündnis allerdings halten
wird ist nicht absehbar
heute gewann die neue regierung ein
vertrauensvotum nur hauchdünn
wenn jetzt erste rede in der knesset
wurde mehrfach von netanjahu anhängern
unterbrochen bei dieser ersten rede
wandte israels neuer ministerpräsident
bennet die islamistische hamas vor neuen
angriffen auf israelische ziele die
wiederum kündigte bereits die
fortsetzung des bewaffneten kampfes
gegen den jüdischen staat an die im
gazastreifen herrschende hamas wird von
eu usa israel als terror organisation
eingestuft
angesichts sinkender corona
infektionszahlen hierzulande hat
bundesjustizministerin lambrecht die
bundesländer aufgefordert zu prüfen ob
und wo eine masken pflicht noch
verhältnismäßig ist wenn die inzidenz
zahlen niedrig sind und weiter sinken
der bild am sonntag sagte sie weiter das
betreffe auch die schulen das robert
koch institut meldet 1489 neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages das sind 900 51
weniger als vor einer woche
die sieben tage inzidenz singt weiter
auf aktuell 17
3 es braucht immer noch vorsicht und die
vielen experten können auch nicht viel
mehr machen als die luft anzuhalten und
das beste zu hoffen dass die pandemie
zwischen dem fortschreiten des sommers
und der impfungen in den hintergrund
gerät
dann bleiben immer noch die folgen des
virus und die kollateralschäden der
bekämpfung des virus und die tauchen
jetzt überall auf zum beispiel auch bei
kindern denen sind ja längst nicht nur
unterrichtseinheiten verloren gegangen
eine reportage von thomas münten die
klasse 2a der hövel schule in essen
altenessen ist hochkonzentriert schnick
schnack schnuck ist angesagt
koordination bewegung und spaß für viele
der kinder ist das die erste echte
bewegung nach sieben monaten zu hause
distanz unterricht hieß das vornehmen
praktisch hörte sich nicht ganz so
gelungen an den ganzen tag gemacht
manchmal dass auch geregnet dann könnte
ich auch nicht raus war ich mit meinem
bruder am 2 wir haben nicht fußball
gedruckt wird ich bin fußballer
ausgerechnet habe ich dann enden ohne
jetzt sagt man dann haben wir immer ohne
gesperrt damit soll nun schluss sein
sportstadt karten playstation die
entwicklungsrückstände eben nicht nur im
sprachvermögen oder im wissenstand in
einzelnen fächern sondern eben vor allen
dingen auch in der fitness der kinder
und das macht uns große sorgen es ist
eben so dass viele kinder gerade bei uns
hier im stadtteil eben nicht die
bewegungsmöglichkeiten zu hause haben
dir da ist eben kein garten da wo sie
mal eben aus trampolin hüpfen können die
radwege sind nicht vernünftig ausgebaut
die spielplätze sind weit entfernt
altenessen ist der größte stadtteil in
essen hier im norden der stadt leben
rund 44.000 menschen jeder vierte ist
arbeitssuchend gemeldet und 30 prozent
haben migrationshintergrund
der stadtteil hat es nicht leicht
überwiegend mehrfamilienhäuser viele
soziale brennpunkte damit die kinder
hier wieder aus ihrer lethargie kommen
arbeitet die schule mit einem
gemeinnützigen spielzeit mobil zusammen
organisiert werden die aktionen von
sportstudenten der nahen universität
hier in altenessen klappt das aber dem
sport professor fehlt ein größeres
konzept ich finde das ist höchste zeit
wird dass wir so was wie ein
marshallplan gerade für diese kinder die
den zugang nicht so leicht fällt wie den
anderen zuspiel sportbewegung dass wir
die für die ideen entwickeln und wenn
ich so die kollegen wären busch in der
hafenschule höhere und so weiter dann
wird es höchste zeit dass die politik
richtig investiert damit diese
generation ist nicht verloren geht
darüber denken die kinder in der schule
nicht nach
sie genießen einfach die spiele und
versuchen so die folgen der pandemie zu
überwinden
viel glück dabei und wir bleiben beim
sport wechseln aber dorthin wo spiel
auch kampf und business bedeutet oder
auch einen tennis krimi bietet das
finale der french open hat novak
djokovic gewonnen nach fünf spannenden
sätzen in über vier stunden gegen den
griechen stefanos tizi pass für djokovic
den rekord weltranglisten-erste aus
serbien ist es der 19 grand slam sieg
seiner karriere
der zweite triumph in roland garros bei
den hockey europameisterschaften in den
niederlanden haben auch die frauen im
finale gegen die gastgeber verloren
ebenso wie gestern die männer des dhb 0
2 unterlag das deutsche team
rekordchampion niederlande zweimal
silber also die ausbeute der deutschen
mannschaften bei der hockey-em der
dänische fußballstar christian eriksen
hatte einen herzstillstand als er
gestern während des spiels gegen
finnland zusammenbrach das ärzte team
erklärte heute nach lebensrettenden
maßnahmen sei sein zustand jetzt stabil
vom krankenhaus aus konnte ericsson
bereits mit seinen team kollegen
sprechen
momente der erleichterung bei dänischen
und finnischen fans als nach eineinhalb
stunden bangen die erlösende nachricht
kam ericssons zustand sei stabil und er
sei bei bewusstsein
auch am tag danach gibt es noch kein
abschließendes medizinisches dossier
aber der dänische team arzt bestätigt
einen herzstillstand
hast du das wars korn heute viel kritik
an der uefa am wieder anpfiff des spiels
nachdem sich beide teams für die
fortsetzung der partie entschieden
hatten
spiele zwischen den zwei szenarien
entscheiden zu lassen ist wenn solche
schlimmen sachen wie bei christian
passieren müssen wir abwägen was am
wichtigsten kulisse most important
mitgefühl zum beispiel wie jogis jungs
mit ihrer grussbotschaft an christian
eriksen finnland hatte das unterbrochene
spiel dennoch gewonnen 100
österreich ist ebenfalls mit einem sieg
in die europameisterschaft gestartet das
3 1 gegen neuling nord mazedonien ist
der erste sieg einer österreichischen
mannschaft bei einer em überhaupt und
zuvor hatte auch england heute einen
sieg gefeiert das 1 0 in london gegen
vize weltmeister kroatien war der erste
sieg der engländer in einem wm
auftaktspiel im zehnten versuch seit
der kniefall von englands nationalelf
zum zeichen gegen rassismus von fast
allen fans beklatscht statt wie zuletzt
darauf zugreifen
dem sportlichen traum statt gegen
kroatien durch folgen steht der pfosten
im wege
sechste minute höhepunkt der neuauflage
des wm halbfinals schon 2018
dieser feine pass von philips und die
verwertung von rahim sterling 57 minute
das tor des tages gegen restlos
enttäuschende kroaten england feiert mit
1 0 den ersten auftaktsieg bei einer
europameisterschaft
der ist kein grund sich zu fürchten in
china ist der drache kein dämonisches
unwesen wie in der germanischen
mythologie sondern ein gott ähnliches
geschöpft seit jahrtausenden stehen
drachen für das reich und für den kaiser
der kaiser hat sich nicht gehalten und
das reich im großen ganzen schule die
verehrung des drachen hat dabei nie
nachgelassen
sie erobern auch seit 2000 jahren schon
die lüfte als erste fluggeräte der
menschheit liebevoll von hand gestaltet
damals wie heute eine reportage aus
unserem studio peking
jede bewegung ist viele tausendmal
ausgeübt von klein auf hat er das
drachen bauen gelernt jeder pinselstrich
sitzt es dauert jahre bis man die
verschiedenen techniken beherrscht
shandong ist 76 und lernt immer noch
dazu
ich bin acht jahre alt gewesen als mein
großvater mir dass drachen bauen
beigebracht hat er fand mich klug und
fleißig und wollte dass ich die
tradition lerne er sitzt oft zwei wochen
an den aufwendigen bunten fabelwesen sie
kosten bis zu 2400 euro
überall gibt es große und kleine
fabriken mehr als 70 prozent der drachen
der welt kommen ausweichen
im schulunterricht lernen sich schon die
tradition des drachen baums aufgereiht
marschieren sie zum fliegen denn darum
geht es
aller anfang ist schwer ich will
unbedingt lernen einen drachen zu bauen
dabei geht es mir nicht nur um mich
sondern darum die tradition weiterleben
zu lassen
das festival in weifang beginn
farbenfroh mit drachen die sich in luft
auflösen
jedes jahr steigen die unglaublichsten
figuren tiere fabelwesen in den himmel
auf bis zu 100000 besucher schauen sich
das spektakel an
wir kommen gerne die atmosphäre ist so
lebendig alle drachen fans besuchen
diesen ort jeder hat gute laune
ding dong jin hat sich dieses jahr eine
besondere attraktion ausgedacht einen
sieben kilometer langen drachen sollte
er fliegen wäre es ein weltrekord an
einer schnur aufgereiht alle drei meter
ein kleiner drachen
normalerweise brauchen wir nicht mehr
als windstärke 3 heute haben wir sieben
aber wir versuchen es trotzdem
der wind wird zum sturm am boden braucht
es viele männer um den längsten drachen
der welt nicht zu verlieren
am ende siegt die natur der wind ist zu
stark die drachenschnur ist gerissen
drachen sind wie menschen sie können zu
großen druck nicht standhalten
sie werden es wieder versuchen den
drachen zu zähmen das ist wohl die
faszination dieser alten tradition der
mensch der mit seinem drachen tanzt
drachen sind wie menschen wir haben
keinen drachen der von weit oben voraus
schauen kann
sieben tage weit wir haben eric
illenseer mit dem ausblick in die woche
[Musik]
der digitale impfausweis viele apotheken
werden ab montag helfen der einen vollen
corona im schutz belegen kann bekommt in
der apotheke oder beim arzt einen qr
code für den nachweis mit dem smartphone
pünktlich zur hauptreisezeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die mosaik expedition die größte
arktis-expedition aller zeiten auf
einladung des forschungsministeriums
wollen führen der wissenschaftler am
dienstag über erste ergebnisse berichten
vor den wechselwirkungen zwischen klima
und 159 millionen wahlberechtigte sind
am freitag in iran aufgerufen über einen
neuen präsidenten abzustimmen
der moderate an zenani darf nach zwei
amtszeiten nicht mehr antreten
beherrschendes thema ist die
wirtschaftskrise die sich auch durch
scharfe sanktionen in der regierung tram
verschlimmert hat ab samstag dann zwei
tage wahlprogramm parteitag der linken
während den teilen der partei über einen
ausschluss sarah wagenknecht diskutiert
wird befinden die mitglieder online über
das programm zur bundestagswahl die
leitgedanken soziale sicherheit frieden
klimagerechtigkeit
und das wetter bringt in dieser neuen
woche hochsommer viel sonne und eine
erste hitzewelle morgen ist es sonnig
und sommerlich warm bei 23 bis 30 grad
nur ganz im norden ziehen am nachmittag
einige kompaktere wolken auf am dienstag
gibt es bei 19 bis 32 grad im norden
wolken im süden sonne danach wird es
zunehmend schwül heiß bei bis zu 36 grad
das war es würden uns für diesen sonntag
und für diese woche maria und heinz
glaube ich übernehmen den job hier ab
morgen und wir sehen uns demnächst
irgendwann wieder ein bisschen an
[Musik]